- [Instructor] Galvanic cells,
which are also called voltaic cells,
use a thermodynamically favorable reaction
to generate an electric current.
Before we look at a diagram
of a galvanic or voltaic cell,
let's first look at the half reactions
that are going to be used in the cell.
In the first half reaction,
zinc metal loses two electrons
to turn into the zinc 2+ cation.
Loss of electrons is oxidation.
Therefore, this is the
oxidation half reaction.
As a quick review, the other way to tell
that this is the oxidation half reaction
is we go from an oxidation number
for solid zinc of zero
to an oxidation number
for zinc 2+ of plus two
and increase in the oxidation
number is oxidation.
Therefore, zinc metal is oxidized.
And here is the other half reaction
that we're going to see in
our galvanic cell diagram.
In this half reaction,
the copper 2+ cation gains two electrons
to turn into solid copper.
Gain of electrons is reduction.
Therefore, this is the
reduction half reaction.
The other way to tell
that this is the reduction
half reaction is to look
at the oxidation numbers.
So the copper 2+ cation has an oxidation
number of plus two and solid copper
has an oxidation number of zero.
Since there's a decrease or a reduction
in the oxidation number
from plus two to zero,
this is the reduction half reaction.
A good way to remember
which half reaction is which
is to think about LEO the lion goes GER.
So loss of electrons is oxidation
and gain of electrons is reduction.
When we add the two
half reactions together,
we have two electrons on the reactant side
and two electrons on the product side.
So those cancel out and
that gives us a solid zinc
plus copper 2+ ions
goes to zinc 2+ cations
and solid copper.
In this redox reaction,
zinc metal is oxidized to zinc 2+ cations
and copper 2+ cations are
reduced to solid copper.
Delta G naught for this reaction
at 25 degrees Celsius or room temperature
is less than zero,
which means this reaction
is thermodynamically favorable.
Therefore, if we were to
put a piece of solid zinc
in an aqueous solution of copper 2+ ions,
we would see copper metal
form on the zinc metal and zinc 2+ ions
would form in solution.
So that's what would happen
if we did this reaction
in only a single compartment.
However, in a galvanic or voltaic cell,
each half reaction gets
its own compartment.
And the two compartments
are connected with a wire.
Therefore, a thermodynamically favorable
redox reaction is used to generate
an electric current in the wire.
And by electric current,
we're talking the flow of electrons.
Now that we've gone
over the half reactions
in detail for this zinc-copper
galvanic or voltaic cell,
let's look at a diagram of this cell
and see how things actually work.
Let's start by looking at
the compartment on the left,
which is a beaker that contains
a one molar aqueous
solution of zinc sulfate.
Therefore, there are zinc 2+ ions
and sulfate anions in aqueous
solution in the beaker.
We saw from the oxidation half reaction
that solid zinc is oxidized
and turns into zinc 2+ cations.
When zinc turns into zinc 2+,
two electrons are lost.
So those electrons will move
in this wire that connects
the two compartments.
So imagine we have movement of electrons
going from the compartment on the left
towards the compartment on the right.
This piece of solid zinc
is called an electrode.
The electrode at which
oxidation takes place
is called the anode.
So let me go ahead and
write anode in here.
Next, let's look at the
compartment on the right,
which is a beaker that contains
a one molar solution of copper sulfate.
So in this beaker,
there are copper 2+ ions
and sulfate anions in aqueous solution.
We know that electrons
are moving in this wire
that connects the two compartments.
At the surface of this copper electrode,
the copper 2+ ions come in contact
with two electrons and are
reduced to form solid copper.
The electrode where reduction takes place
is called the cathode.
So the copper electrode is
the cathode for this cell.
I went ahead and rewrote
each half reaction
to remind us of what's going
on in each compartment.
So we can think about what's gonna happen
to our cell over time.
The anode is where oxidation takes place.
So solid zinc turns into zinc 2+ cations.
So as time goes on,
the amount of the solid
zinc electrode will decrease.
And the amount of zinc 2+ cations
in solution will increase.
And the cathode is where
reduction takes place.
So as copper 2+ cations gained
two electrons to turn into solid copper,
over time, the amount of copper,
solid copper electrode will increase.
And the concentration of copper 2+ ions
in solution will decrease.
A good way to remember that oxidation
occurs at the anode and
reduction occurs at the cathode
is to think about two
animals, an ox and a cat.
So thinking about an ox reminds us
that oxidation occurs at the anode
and thinking about a red cat
reminds us that reduction
occurs at the cathode.
The next part of the cell
that we have to think about
is the salt bridge that connects
these two compartments.
Inside the salt bridge,
there's an electrolyte solution
such as sodium nitrate.
The electrolyte is often in a gel
or paste form to prevent early mixing
with the other compartments.
These solutions in each compartment
also called a half cell must
remain electrically neutral.
And the purpose of the salt bridge
is to balance the charges.
Let's start by thinking
about the compartment
or the half cell on the left.
When we started, we had
equal concentrations
of zinc 2+ and sulfate anion,
so the charges were balanced.
However, over time, the concentration
of zinc 2+ ions increases.
To balance out the
increased positive charge,
the negatively charged anion,
and in this case, the nitrate anion,
moves from the salt bridge
into the half cell on the left.
Next, let's think about the compartment
or the half cell on the right.
We started off with equal concentrations
of copper 2+ cation and sulfate anion.
However, over time, there's a
decrease in copper 2+ cation.
Therefore, there's too
much negative charge
in this half cell.
To balance out the negatively
charged sulfate anions,
the positively charged
ion and the salt bridge,
in this case, the sodium cation,
moves from the salt bridge
into the half cell on the right.
A good way to remember which direction
the ions go in the salt bridge
is to think about anions
going toward the anode
and cations going toward the cathode.
The salt bridge is necessary
for the galvanic cell to work.
If the salt bridge were removed,
the electrons would
stop moving in the wire,
And that brings us to the last component
of our galvanic cell, which
is this volt meter here.
For this particular galvanic cell
with one molar concentration
of zinc sulfate,
one more concentration of copper sulfate
at 25 degrees Celsius,
the initial voltage would be 1.10 volts.
So that's what would show
up on the volt meter.
The volt meter measures the difference
in electric potential between two points.
And as long as there's a difference
in electric potential,
electrons will flow in the wire.
However, this thermodynamically favorable
redox reaction doesn't last forever.
Eventually, the reaction
reaches equilibrium.
And at that point, the
voltage is equal to zero.
And when the voltage goes to zero,
the current also goes to zero,
which means the electrons
are no longer moving in the wire.
You could also call a galvanic
or voltaic cell a battery.
So at that point, the battery is dead.
Let's do a quick summary of
galvanic or voltaic cells.
These cells use a thermodynamically
favored redox reaction.
This redox reaction generates
an electric current that flows
in the wire between the two electrodes.
The electrode where oxidation takes place
is called the anode,
and the electrode where
reduction takes place
is called the cathode.
A salt bridge is used
to balance the charges
in the two compartments.
Eventually, the reaction
reaches equilibrium
and at equilibrium, the
voltage is equal to zero,
which means there's no more current.
And the galvanic or
voltaic cell stops working.